有什么指标可以预测股价
接下来会创新高
K线补手杨宗献老师
今天要教大家的这个指标
一定要学起来哦
轻松学投资
投资轻松赞
我是玉琴
哈喽大家好
杨宗献老师好
玉琴好
各位同学大家好
杨宗献老师
好久不见哦
对对很久不见
听说你今天要来
跟我们介绍一个很
特别的指标
好像他不只可以确认这个趋势
还可以预测啊
对对对
可以预测说
我们这个股票会创新高
对非常重要
是什么指标呢
这个指标叫做OBV指标
我们一般简称它
叫OBV
好像比较少人看
比较少人
对因为它不是天天在看
是在你的关键时候才在看
才要看
对
好
那我们这个指标
大概介绍一下
就是说
它这个发明人
叫做葛兰币
葛兰币
很热熟对不对
很有名耶
对对就是葛兰币八大法
同一个人
好
那这个指标
它是把那个
我們一般這個量不是柱狀圖嗎
對一根一根啊
可是你有時候很難看
紅綠紅綠對不對
看不懂
所以它把它轉換成這個折線圖
就會非常清楚
好那我們來看一家示範
像這個台積電
它上面這個是柱狀圖有沒有
對這就是成交量
對可是看了好像有看沒懂對不對
我看得出來量變多還是變少
對但只有單一根
它把它累加起來之後發現
這邊量是縮的
然後這個量是有上來的
趨勢會比較明顯
就看到一個像趨勢線的感覺
就會把這個本來柱狀體的東西
把它變成一個趨勢
就很明朗
OK
那我們說這個OBB
它有很多實戰功能
非常多
那我們擷取最重要的就好了
不然這個要講半小時的講不完
對 你把課都拿來上了
對對對
那首先這個
它可以判斷趨勢的多頭空頭跟盤整
這是第一個功能
第二個功能是
它是一個同步指標
做確認用的
就是確認
確認用的
比較重要的是它是領先指標
也就是說我們可以預知說
這個股票未來會不會創新高
這好重要喔
最喜歡這個喔可以告訴我嗎這個功能呢預測未來能不能創新高還能夠搭配我們的形態學的旗形,兩個結合在一起,做一些輔助工具,哎呀,勝率會覺得更高了,
沒有錯,好,
那最後一個是我們慣性會跟大家提醒,
就是說每個指標都有它的缺點,
所以我們在使用上要注意的一些注意事項,
OK,好,
那我們第一個來看,像這個,
我們在這個骨架在多頭走勢的時候,
那下面這個量也是有沒有,
感覺會一時往上啊,
對對對,所以說,
我們因為多頭是駕長量增,
所以說就會往上走
所以它跟量是做對應的
所以這樣子看起來是同步的
對對是同步的
它可以作為趨勢的判斷
好那空頭一樣
叫做架跌量縮
所以我們量就往下走
好那盤整的時候怎麼樣
就胡躲烏空
看不懂的時候
對一下子上去下
好但是
我們這個功能
看趨勢多空盤整
其實是它的一個小小的功能而已
不是那麼重要
重頭戲在下面
是什麼勒
就是我們剛剛說的這個
作為確認工具
好你看这个股价对不对
我们突破盘等区这个地方
小小的红K棒
那这时候是不是股价创新高
那股价创新高之后
我们下面的OBB
是不是同步也创新高
这是正常现象
所以我们在股价上涨过程中
你要去注意说
我们这个价格上去的量也要上来
这样子趋势比较明确
对对这是健康的方式
好那有一种要很注意的就是说
我们股价上去的量没有上去
我们看地段
怎么办
是我们看这个11月2号这个地方
好
股价是不是创新高
是的
好那是不是成交量创新高
就是红色这一块
对红色这一块是OK的
好那但是蓝色股价创新高
但是成交量怎么样
下来了
对那这就是我们说的就是高档背影
那意思就是要小心了对不对
对就是它是个领先反转的现象
就是多投到高档去的时候
那这个时候就可以领先告诉我们
对
接下来有可能要反转
对有可能会修正
反转
对对有反转
对好这是它的第二个功能
好那我们往下看
那這個是我們最喜歡的
你剛剛最喜歡對不對
就是我們去預示說
這個股價會不會創新高
因為我們都做多嘛
好那我們首先來看這個
這個股價在盤整的時候
它到這個地方才創新高才突破對不對可是我們這個OBB怎麼樣他提早三天他就已經先創新高了所以老師下一次我看到這個OBB在下面
創新高的時候
但股價還沒創新高
我是不是就可以先試單
對沒有錯聰明
你可以分批嘛
我們就分批先試單
好
那有一種情況是說
我們可以把它跟我們的旗行做組合
因為我們可以領先
知道他會創新高對不對
那我們旗行的這個邏輯就是
我们是上涨盘整
之后再续涨
对不对
好那我们怎么知道
这个期型会不会出现
对我们就会搭配OBB
好我们来
我们先画形态
再跟你搭配指标
好我们往下看一下
好你看哦
我们这个股价
在这个地方哦
才突破
对啊
可是我们这个
那个OBB呢
我们在1月初
我们就已经突破了
老师这不只领先3天
这领先很久
对对没有错
所以说你心里
就会有个底
好但是我们要强调说
这个领先指标
你不要冲太快
我们建议说
一样
你在这个区间
你可以先试单
等到突破
再做加码的动作
你就做分别
因为像我们刚刚讲的
你运气好
三天就突破了
对
有时候等这么久
等了一个月
对
那就会熬不过去嘛
所以说你如果
那个张数
比如十张
你先买个三张以下
一张两张三张
那等突破
再去做积极的加码
所以这也是一种
买进的策略搭配了
是没有错
好
那我们之后来总结一下
就是OBB的
使用的注意事項
首先第一個
因為這個中小型股
它的量
尤其小型股
那些不知名的股票
平常都沒有量
然後它漲了之後
量就出來了
本來那種個位數
什麼五張十張
突然變成幾千張
那種股票基本上
OBV就比較不準
所以老師
怎麼樣才算是小
好我覺得如果用
因為我講的具體的數字
我覺得大概抓500張
就是平均
譬如說10日均量
在500張以上
它會比較穩定
對,這樣會有一個比較具體的方向
好,那第二個是
股票如果出現急漲急跌
或者是會有無量突然漲停
連續漲停或連續跌停是沒有量的因為沒有量,這個指標就是以量為主的對,沒有錯,這個指標依舊不大無量的時候我們就不要用就不要用了,就跳過,不要看它
好,再來一個很重要的事情就是說
你在空頭的,你看我剛剛講的都是講多頭對不對
你發現我沒有講空頭
因為空頭的時候這個指標是不存在的
對,因為空頭我們說
多頭是不是價漲量增,價跌量縮
可是空頭有兩種
空头可能价跌量缩
也可能价跌量增
因为空头末跌段会赶出量
所以不同阶段的空头是不一样
我们无法判断说
它到底是哪个阶段的空头
所以说在空头的结构的时候
尽量不要去用OBB
它不是用在空头结构
其实价量关系的指标
通通不是用在空头
因为它有两种可能很极端
所以说没有办法判断
那最后一个就是说
当股价开高走低的时候
当天可能会收涨
像这个地方
我们来看这个图
好的
好
我们看一下
这个股票
股价上涨
到末段
这一根
你是涨
当天收盘是涨
问题是
它出现爆量上一些
可是我们会
如果我们看单一根
K半
我们就知道说
这根不太对
这不是好现场
问题是我们看指标
看不出来
你会发现
OBP还在冲新高
所以这个就是
这个指标的计算公式的问题
它很简单
但它相对就是说
它会有这个问题
就是说
我们会把空方量
把它放到变成多方量
对
所以说这个时候你还是要搭配这个单力跟K棒
去做应对这样子
好哦
谢谢老师的提醒
今天老师介绍的这个OBV指标呢
其实非常的实用
它可以用来确认
也可以用来预测
不过使用上有一些小的PayPal要注意的
提供给大家参考咯
那我们谢谢杨忠贤老师
希望下一次还有机会
邀请老师来
谢谢大家
拜拜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive